foreign
[Music]
I think what we have here in Hollywood
is high Arts it's party time
[Applause]
you could go anywhere in the whole world
where would you go
I always wanted to be part of something
bigger yes let's go
you think that last that means something
[Applause]
[Music]
you know when I first moved to LA yeah
you know it shines on all the doors red
no actors or dogs allowed
I changed that good morning good job for
you I'll do anything that's the jackass
they said to screw us
[Applause]
[ __ ] is stealing the scene right from
under me she icing her nipples so they
Park up through her dress iron eyes in
my nipples this is natural
where do you say we come in for my
close-up now
what are your thoughts for the future
shouldn't stand in the way of progress
because it's gonna be what it's gonna be
The Twist whoa
the girl seems nice she is she has no
idea what's next
there's some new sensibility now people
care about Morris
I've never done nothing to disappoints
people my whole life but I made it on my
terms not theirs
[Music]
we are going to be more than they ever
bargained for
thank you
what I do means something
and I'm going to bed
[Music]
thank you